we've spent sort of three and a half
four seasons taking what was supposed to
be the hero of the show and breaking him
down I actually think there's a lot of
really great writing on television and
it's it's a great medium and there's
really cool storytelling and people can
take more risk in television because
you're not having to reach out to
massive film audiences I'm just really
kind of looking forward to a time where
I'm not roped into the same project in
the same character in the same story for
such a long period of time
John Stuart Rome is burning I watch a
lot of ESPN I do watch a lot of things
on PBS I love frontline and Nova
I think that most of the audience of
loss even though they when they see you
they're their first impulses like tell
me something I'm dying to know the same
impulse of if you're reading a great
book and the same impulse you have to
turn to the end and make sure everything
works out already most of the time a I
don't know the answers to the questions
that they would ask to be if I do know
the answer and I were to start to tell
them they would stop me because I think
they really they want to watch it unfold
anybody who watches the show at this
point knows that the last year of the
show he's just become sort of you know a
really messed up individual the nice
thing about this year is that I'm gonna
get an opportunity to begin to redeem
the character the character is gonna go
back to the island and be convinced that
that's his only that that is his destiny
and that there is something left for him
to do there
I think that most the time I have people
reference party at five or Charlie
Salinger because they want to prove to
you that they've been a fan of you or
things that you've been involved in for
a long time people want to go like no I
was a fan or I watched party five they
kind of want to indicate to you that
they've known about you for a long time
it's got wolf a bit you know I haven't
seen Scott in a little while but we
touch base with each other every now and
then Nevin lacy I haven't spoken to her
singing in a long time
I'd love to bump into them sometime